[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les forces de l'ordre en nombre et
l'interdiction de manifester ne les ont
pas dissuadé plusieurs centaines de
participants convoi 10 des libertés ont
envahi la place de l'étoile et les
champs elysées cet après midi
enfin la dualité très compliqué très
froide donc voilà ça va continuer à
manifester à faire le convoi aller sur
paris et puis après on ira à bruxelles
s'il faut
à l'actualité diplomatique de la france
déconseillent désormais à ses
ressortissants et bien de se rendre en
ukraine
annonce du quai d'orsay qui ne demandent
pas pour l'instant à ceux qui s'y
trouvent de quitter le pays
emmanuel macron a refusé de faire un
test pcr pour éviter que les russes et
son adn selon un proche du président
cité par l'agencé reuters est ce que
vous auriez eu cette méfiance nommé je
suis moi je pense que cette anecdote est
grotesque à lusa l'adjoint pourquoi bas
ne serait ce que parce que en posant ses
mains sur la table qui voulaient les
russes avaient la possibilité d'avoir un
adn qui doit avoir d'ailleurs depuis
bien longtemps mais cette campagne
présidentielle avec vous c'est un peu la
guerre des étoiles il ya un peu la
menace fantôme c'est la gauche il ya un
peu l'empiré contre attaque c'est macron
fort encore faudrait-il que l'on pirates
à l'attaqué des clones
eric zemmour marine le pen bon vous avez
compris que moi j'étais l'heureux le
retour du jedi
voilà quelqu'un si je ne me trompe pas
il a démarré chez vous et un bon gros un
peu comme s il y célébrer ce un peu
comme eric zemmour après leur carrière
bifurque entrevue mais quel succès ces
deux là qui avait eric bergeron contre
je peux avoir dû voir edel coupet
s'est emparé du cian healy david ferrer
j'ai démarré au même endroit qu'ils
aient mon toit tu finiras même endroit
gfr
depuis le confinement le curé poste
régulièrement des vidéos sur le réseau
des danses à la mode
sur des musiques aux paroles envoûtantes
j'ai faut le qg
azam aux
soarns céline des occitans de berne et
le pire n'est toutefois ni voté pour lui
après ses performances de ce soir
franchement je ne pense pas je pense pas
malheureusement mais il est vraiment
utile dans la dans la politique actuelle
oui
alors lequel de ces trois talents
repartira avec la victoire de la
révélation masculine
je sentais ok c'était le risque lolibé
ya toujours une séquence cascade dans
une grande cérémonie c'est le chic est
alors en 2021 date routine est c'est le
vrai chiffre a fait 22 morts bravo anne
hidalgo et leurs doubles c'est le but de
fournir airs de cour à roanne
alors non
de diawara qui les assassiner
directement je n'ai pas dit ça mais si
on fait la comptabilité et camionnettes
trottinette voilà michel a été moins
dangereux je suis eu une émission du
service public un samedi soir tout va
bien il n'y a pas d'agressivité
il a simplement un homme qui dit oui un
autre qui dit non c'est interdit ça dans
mon beau pays dans ce pays des droits de
l'homme encore une page ou pas être je
peux faire le droit de l'hommiste pays
de la liberté d'expression puis la
culture pays la littérature prix de la
musique pays où les artistes sont
exceptionnels même le président de
l'époque qui n'était pas un camembert
c'était pompidou il avait parlé de thé
cactus à l'assemblée et je crois que je
crois que tu as chanté même tu m'avais
raconté sais pas si on peut leur a conté
tracts à chanter devant lui en en
caleçon serre qui est il a dit à ses
musiciens venez on va chanter en caleçon
ils ont posé mais lui il ya été paraît
que tout le monde était très choquée à
l'elysée mais que ça fait beaucoup rire
pompidou qui avait de l'humour avec ce
pays sublime de beauté on n'a pas le
droit un samedi soir de dire à monsieur
edwy plenel je ne suis pas d'accord avec
vous je trouve que vos méthodes ne sont
pas bonnes dites moi mais c'est
hallucinant on marche sur la tête là il
faut interdire l'importation de
production qui ne respectent pas nos
normes on est à 84,7 milliards de
déficit là je suis en train de vous
parler ce qui va se passer au mois
d'août de cette année c'est à dire les
français vont plus avoir produit si vous
êtes en train de dire maintenant on
interdit les entrées mais c'est comme ça
que ça va c'est à dire que complètement
aux antipodes rand dévoyer la sortie de
me prendre pour une idiote jeu sera
présent mais bien sûr merci papa
dernière idée eh bien je retrouve un
jour
il ya un truc qui me fascine c'est à
barbe je trouve ça fait sinon tu te
rases plus depuis combien de temps pour
ma tante a une copine qui seul qui me
fait une fois par mois elle te fait une
fois par mois là
l aveugle pardon olawa
à bandar est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé donc tu es
en stage à la taupe est compagnie parce
que nous on l'appelle la taupe est
compagnie à proposer une question oui
j'ai proposé une question sur olivia
rodrigo
c'est génial elle vient de donner la rue
c'est quand même
merci beaucoup je vous embrasse
la vie et à bientôt sur les rangs
merci à tous les deux jacques dutronc
thomas dutronc jacques si vous
m'entendez je ne suis pas sûr je ne
crois qu'il ne l'entend pas mais ces
remerciements ont été faits dans la
halle dans la chanson évidemment on
s'est pas retourné alors que vous avez
votre place aussi parce que vous avez
super bien chanté merci c'est vrai et on
peut juste s'excuse lmc c'est con mais
c'est comme ça un métier si on veut y
aller faut y aller en fait mais non j'ai
50 mecs à écouter mais arrête de me dire
des conneries g50 mais qu'à écouter ça
veut juste dire que je vais dire à 48
personnes aubin c'est formidable où
chantait super bien et je peux pas
appuyer s qui
voilà la tradition manquera pas grand
chose que vous
jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
c
je 100e
25 secondes en
ce 100e
vient de pulvériser de plus de sept
secondes le record du genre